bonsoir à tous et merci de nous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro de
kiosques votre magazine culturel sur
saint quentin en yvelines et ses
environs tout de suite le sommaire de
cette émission mercredi 3 février
gail pinault est en plateau pour nous
présenter ciné junior
le festival international du cinéma
jeune public initialement créé en val de
marne la 26e édition du festival passera
jusqu'au 16 février par mines par magny
les hameaux et l'encours et trappes
franceville est également en plateau
avec nous évoquera les nouveautés de la
7e édition du festival international du
film court de jouy en josas l'ombre d'un
cours
ce sera du 5 au 7 février encore
quelques jours pour découvrir une
exposition originale à la galerie à
l'écu de france de viroflay lettres de
femmes vous propose de découvrir les
étapes nécessaires à la réalisation d'un
film en stop motion et on ouvre cette
émission spéciale septième art vous
l'aurez compris avec vous galles pineau
bonsoir alors vous êtes le responsable
du grenier à sel de trappes et vous
participez au concours au festival ciné
junior
c'est un festival qui est originaire du
val de marne et qui cette année passera
donc par le ciné 7 d'elancourt
l'estaminet de magny les hameaux et le
grenier à sel de trappes pourquoi avoir
souhaité s'associer à ce festival
alors nous sommes en contact avec
l'envié de l'association qui organise le
festival depuis de nombreuses années
pour d'autres choses nos collections ce
festival puisque ça ma 6ème édition et
comme nous travaillons depuis de très
très très très nombreuses années avec
les enfants dans le cadre de dispositifs
d'éducation au cinéma avec les centres
de loisirs avec les écoles etc etc on
n'avait pas la capacité nous de mettre
en place à un festival nous mêmes on
n'avait pas les épaules
du coup la participation quand ils nous
ont proposé l'année dernière 2
de travailler avec eux on a tout de
suite sauté sur l'occasion pour vous
vraiment le développement de l'allier
cinéma chez le jeune public c'est
quelque chose qui est important de
développer de promouvoir alors comme je
faisais pour nous c'est presque le coeur
de notre métier
at rattrape en tout cas on a vraiment
envie d'apporter des choses aux enfants
aux élèves et
donc on travaille avec l'éducation
nationale sur des dispositifs dont je
parlais tout à l'heure mais maintenant
on a envie aussi d'ouvrir aux familles
et donc oui pour moi le développement
est très très très important c'est un
citoyen ça permet un éveil le libre
arbitre
qu'est-ce que ça développe alors voilà
vous avez dit les mots qui sont vraiment
importants tout ça on est on est entouré
d'image mais saturé d'image il faut
aussi avoir son livre arbitres il faut
avoir la capacité de juger des images et
ben est pas tout absorber 5 c'est la
réponse assez simple et assez classique
mais mais c'est vrai qu'on est aussi le
cinéma c'est aussi un art donc on a
aussi eu besoin des fois d'être
accompagnés ou pour apprécier des choses
où on a aussi besoin de savourer des
choses donc là on a des courts métrages
qui sont très différents et permettre un
éveil qui permettent un éveil et une
sensibilisation à tout ça puisque on est
habitué à voir des longs film d'une
heure et demie deux heures et c'est là
on est on est vraiment sur des formes
courtes et qui sont très adaptés pour
tout le monde d'ailleurs est sélectionné
alors en plateau également avec nous
from villette bonsoir vous êtes le
président de l'association et film
d'avenir qui organise le festival de
courts métrages de jeu en rosace l'ombre
d'un cours pour vous le développement
également du cinéma chez le jeune public
c'est important oui mais tout à fait
d'ailleurs on a une journée spéciale
aussi pour le jeune public le dimanche
donc dimanche qui vient et on a voulu
aussi m
en avant le court métrage auprès auprès
du jeune public parce que je pense que
c'est important vous avez dit les mots
pour l'éveil l'apprentissage la
découverte
c'est important aussi de leur montrer
autre chose que ce qui se passe à la
télé notamment et sur internet
alors on reviendra dans quelques
instants sur votre festival on continue
avec vous gaël donc le festival ciné
junior démarre aujourd'hui se poursuit
jusqu'au 16 février prochain
et dans ce cas trouve vous organisés
dans votre salle au grenier à sel
mercredi 10 février une compétition donc
de courts métrages il ya deux programmes
de compétition 14h30
six courts métrages pour les 7 10 ans
avec notamment le cours de natation on
en regarde tout de suite un extrait
et le samedi alors à 15 heures l'autre
partie de la compétition pour les 3 6
ans six autres courts métrages que vous
proposez dont la loi du plus fort un
extrait vous avez souhaité dissocier
gaël ces deux compétitions par rapport à
la grande différence d'analysé de
compréhension qui existe entre les
enfants de ces deux tranches d'âge
alors c'est beaucoup plus simple que ça
c'est qu'en fait ce soir c'est une
compétition officielle dans le festival
dans le cadre du festival et
et donc il ya un fait c'est une
compétition pour les films de 3 à 6 ans
et pour les films de 6 à 12 ans et donc
à deux programmes différents donc
on en a le mercredi et le samedi
ce qui est important c'est que les
spectateurs qui viendront grenier à sel
vont voter y aura le prix du public ça
sera reconnue officiellement dans le
festival
voilà donc on n'aura pas les résultats
en sortant de la séance et comment vous
avez élire du coup le lauréat en fait
comment est ce que le public va pouvoir
voter alors nous on sera on sera là dans
la salle on veut pas seulement passer le
film ait donné un petit papier on sera
là pour parler des films où on comptera
au fait entre chaque film pour discuter
de ce qu'on vient de voir puisque on a
des enfants qui peuvent être assez
jeunes et leur donner leur demander leur
avis et de voter donner des notes sur
des films c'est pas forcément évident
donc on sera là pour accompagner st et
c'est nous qui retranscrit pour
retranscrivons après les résultats
d'accor alors je vous invite à retrouver
toutes les dates du ciné junior sur
saint quentin en yvelines jusqu'au 16
février prochain à l'adresse qui
s'affiche à l'écran
gaël vous êtes venus également nous
parler de la soirée night faire que vous
organisez vendredi 5 février à 20h45
mais avant les coups tout de suite vos
réactions sur le film à la fiche le
chocolat puis c'était très bien joué
vraiment très bien joué et je trouve que
c'est bien de remettre à l'honneur des
gens qui ont lutté pour leur liberté
dans reconnaissance c'est vraiment extra
et en plus haut marche i joue vachement
bien
toute cette époque
et aussi la tristesse mais le mélodrame
enfin quand même une île une histoire
authentique
c'est je m'attendais pas à ça un très
beau film plein de sentiments et puis
omar sy les perf un super acteur et le
coup de coeur du professionnel cette
semaine c'est le vôtre gueule allons
vous écoute
bonjour cette semaine je voudrais vous
parler du film night faire nous recevons
le réalisateur ce vendredi 5 février à
20h45
l'heureux night faire c'est l'histoire
d'un taxi basket qui tourne mal
c'est l'histoire d'un chauffeur de taxi
justicier s'est réalisé par julien seri
junayd faire c'est son quatrième long
métrage est finalement d'aller faire ses
fesses un film d'amis s'est fait avec
des amis de ses amis à lui qu'ils ont
cherché des financements sur internet
il y a eu 700 contributeurs qui le
soutiennent et par lui et à de grands
noms et les grands réalisateurs français
et les grands acteurs français
le film s'est tourné en trois mois de
l'écriture au tournage et c'est
extrêmement courts pour tourner un film
côté casting on découvre gestio d'un qui
est génial en chauffeur de taxi gersois
d'entre nous ne connaît pas c'est un
conte combattant ufc donc ultimate
fighting c'est à celui qui fait le
chauffeur de taxi il y à jonathan
d'eward qui est à jouer dans world war z
qui a joué dans thor dans doctor who nab
et moi j'aime ce film night faire car il
a une économie avec des habituels et
c'est une démarche que j'ai envie de
soutenir
il a été en plus ils étaient tournés sur
saint quentin en yvelines dont marc
clément vous reconnaîtrai des images et
la ville est très belle dans le film je
vais bien c'est lloris et écrire il
s'est filmé d'enfiler un twist dans
l'histoire qui révèlent le rôle sur
promenons du chauffeur de taxi
on n'est pas plus surprise c'est un
virage à 90 degrés dans le scénario qui
a mené par une super séquences animées
et
film d'animation et certaines hommage à
kiev il s'est vraiment très très beau et
ça marche très bien et puis bien sûr on
se laisse rattraper par l'atmosphère on
est porté par la musique c'est un peu
comme on braille musique électronique
je précise qu'en première partie de la
srg programme le court métrage amateur
local qui s'appelle le prochain qui dure
neuf minutes
il est réalisé par rémi cluzeau et -
morning c'est aussi un thriller et du
coup il fait très bonne introduction à
nice faire vous retrouvez les images de
tout ça sur notre site internet
www.cineagde.com à vendredi
rendez-vous donc vendredi 5 février
20h45 au grenier à sel de trappes pour
rencontrer l'équipe du film night faire
un mot sur cette rencontre gaël
oui moi je très content de m'en j'en ai
déjà perdu pas mal mais je suis très
content de passer themelin
en fait il a été c'est le producteur qui
est saint quentin c'est un des
producteurs qu'être
saint-quentin-en-yvelines donc du coup
qui a ramené le tournage ici 90 % des
voix sur les images le bâtiment de
téléphiles dans le dans le film on voit
là vous l'aviez reçus des séries ici
quand il est venu parler du tournage
valette ça vous fait envie bah oui ni
non plus rien c'est les jeux wii je
connais ce qu'il fait c'est toujours
assez surprenant intense et la rue et ce
projet là en plus je le suis depuis
depuis un moment sur les réseaux sociaux
et puis on a vu la progression du projet
qui n'est pas facile à mettre en place
c'était difficile nous avaient expliqué
leur font dalle est avec vous on reste
dans le court métrage
parce que pour la 7e édition du festival
ombres du cours de jouy en josas
le festival se passe du 5 au 7 février
35 films français et étrangers en
compétition on regarde tout de suite un
teaser de votre festival
et
m
alors il y en a pour tous les âges on
l'a vu pour tous les gens les la
nouveauté cette année c'est la
compétition du court en 48 heures chrono
ou expliqué me voilà on a lancé ce
projet avec la ville pour créer on va
dire du mouvement dans la ville
puisqu'on a imposé pour ce concours 48
heures de que le tournage se situe à
jouy en josas a même donc le tournage a
eu lieu il ya deux semaines et on a
sélectionné on a lancé un appel à
candidatures pour pouvoir tourner ce
film et on a retenu
on a retenu deux équipes qui sont venus
tourner à joe jonas et on verra le
résultat en clôture du samedi donc les
contraintes c'était écrire tourner et
monter un court métrage
encore un truc tu rajoutes un jose a sur
le thème première rencontre voilà
c'était quoi ce thème première rencontre
bah on cherchait un thème assez
fédérateur pas trop clivant non plus
donc on s'est dit assez ouvert donc et
ses dix premières rencontres c'est la
première fois qu'on propose ce projet
dont on consomme où les paramètres
première fois donc on dit c'est la
première rencontre la rencontre entre le
48 heures entre la ville et entre les
équipes qui vont tourner à jouy en josas
donc voilà première rencontre il une
durée imposée s'est fait foi son travail
à 270 vous voulez jouer pardon les
jouets avec le 78 du département donc
cent soixante dix huit secondes et 272
second c'était à peu près 4 minutes 30
durée imposée alors le genre et le le
format était libre pour les réalisateurs
mais on a imposé aussi une contrainte
technique au moment du lancement du
concours le vendredi soir et cette
contrainte s'est plongée contre-plongée
donc il y aura la ville de juin je sais
ce qui remettra un prix justement de ces
deux équipes et une autre jolie surprise
également pour cette édition c'est la
rencontre professionnelle que vous
organisez pour le grand public samedi 6
février à 18h pour l'avant-première du
moyen métrage dehors tu vas avoir si
froid c'est ça voilà d'arnaud sadowski
c'est la première fois qu'on propose un
moyen métrage
et cette rencontre professionnelle
effectivement l'organisent à 18 heures
et il y aura une belle affiche on va
dire puisque il y aura de dounia coesens
et valérie box qui sont assez connus du
public pour ceux qui connaissent sa plus
belle la vie entre autres y aura julie
de bona aussi et puis il ya un autre
film qui est diffusée avec avec ce moyen
métrage à 18 heures c'est marleau de
sarah barzic
et avec la tête d'affiche jean pierre
mocky et jean pierre mocky ce sera là un
invité exceptionnel donc je vous invite
à venir à 18h rencontré jean-pierre
notice ça vaut son pesant d'or c'est un
bon gars mais vous effectivement alors
de nombreux prix à gagner notamment
grand prix du jury et prix du scénario
au prix de la mise en scène est bien sûr
prix du public
qu'est-ce qui composent le jury a le
jury professionnel
oui oui c'est les films à venir c'est
nous qui contactent ont des
personnalités connues ou pas connu
d'ailleurs on essaie vraiment de varier
notamment dans les personnalités puis
variés aussi dans les fonctions que ce
soit donc des acteurs ou des techniciens
c'est important pour nous de varier les
les fonctions au sein même d'un jury et
puis voilà après au selon les emplois du
temps c'est toujours difficile de réunir
un parterre de
deux jurys mais on a trouvé cette année
donc on à jean christophe bouvet qui est
un acteur c'est connu aussi du public à
laurent firode il ya sylvie fait et
gérard de salles qui est acteur et
acteurs de doublage assez assez connu
aussi et il ya emmanuel d'orlan nous qui
est originaire de versailles
voilà qui est musicien et compositeur il
faut le noter alors donc 35 films en
compétition français et étrangers sur
trois jours du 5 au 7 février
toutes les dates pour le festival
l'ombre d'un cours de jouy en josas à
retrouver sur l'adresse qui s'affiche à
l'écran del pino franck valette
merci d'avoir été en plateau avec nous
et cinéma toujours encore quelques jours
pour profiter de l'exposition lettres de
femmes à la galerie à l'écu de france de
viroflay une exposition originale pour
découvrir l'envers du décor d'un film
d'animation de l'écriture du storyboard
aux étapes de postproduction tous les
secrets d'un film en stop motion vous
sont révélés pendant la première guerre
mondiale simon l'infirmier soigne les
soldats blessés par les lettres d'amour
envoyées par leurs femmes lettre qui ont
le pouvoir de guérir ses soldats sans
papiers lettres de femmes un court
métrage de dix minutes réalisé par
augusto à nos vélos en 2013 prix du
public lors du festival d'annecy la même
année
l'envers du décor de ce film d'animation
vous est proposée à la galerie à l'écu
de france de viroflay
à la suite du film d'animation j'ai
pensé que ce serait
intéressant de montrer comment comment
on fait un film mais je voulais montrer
le travail d'équipé aussi qu'ils étaient
faits c'est-à-dire toute la partie
préparatoire
l'idée c'est de montrer des éléments
toutes sortes d'éléments qui vont de la
conception à la réalisation c'est à dire
le film montre et de l'écriture du
scénario phase de post production en
passant par le storyboard et l'ani matic
toutes les étapes de réalisation du film
sont expliqués jusqu'au secrets du
tournage en stop motion
le saut prochain en fait c'est juste la
traduction de l'image par image l'image
par image c'est à dire que on a besoin
pour avoir la sensation du mouvement de
de 24 images seconde en film en image
par image
on a là on a en reconstitue l'animation
d'un personnage ou d'un objet ce qui
veut dire qu'il faut faire 24 photos
pendant fouras pour obtenir une seconde
de film d'anciennes machines ayant
préfigurer le cinéma issue de la
collection d'eric l'ange sont également
présentés une exposition à découvrir
jusqu'au 7 février
ainsi qu'un ensemble de rencontres
conférences sur le même thème jusqu'au 2
avril et vient de nous rejoindre en
plateau l'équipe du concours de vidéos
sur smartphone concours coûte film
organisé en collaboration avec la
cinémathèque française alors en plateau
lice du pain bonsoir
hélène jacquemin bonsoir marie pons
daisy effet si l'art at elle alors
bonsoir à toutes les quêtes vous êtes
toutes les quatre étudiantes à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en master 2 de management de
communication des organisations et
membres alors de l'équipe coup de films
on va revenir avec vous ses cils qui est
en charge du pilotage global du projet
sur la naissance de ce projet dont qui
fait partie de votre master mais comment
est-ce que vous êtes dit on va réaliser
et un concours coup de films alors à la
base ans et retrouver tous les cinq à la
rentrée sans se connaître et on était
tous attirés par deux thématiques qui
était le cinéma et la vidéo sur
smartphone donc ont cherché des idées
autour de ce thème pour organiser une
action de communication on a été attirée
en fait par l'exposition de martin
scorsese organisait la cinémathèque
française qui nous a poussés à nous
renseigner nous renseigner sur la
cinémathèque savoir ce qu'elle faisait
exactement quelle était sa cible quelles
étaient ses accents communication et on
a trouvé intéressant d'organiser un
concours de films sur smartphone en
collaboration avec eux donc on leur a
proposé coup de films au mois de
novembre 2015 et depuis coups de fil
mais bien réelle alors il ya une raison
particulière en plus pour cette volonté
de s'associer à la cinémathèque c'est
parce qu'à la base il ya eu une
confusion entre forum des images
cinémathèque vous trouviez que c'était
pas assez connu c'est ça c'est s'il en
fait il y avait le forum des images et
très parisien et la cinémathèque
française et représente la culture
cinématographique en france et c'est
vrai qu'on a fait un petit sondage à
travers la classe et on a fait donc une
étude poussée pour pour vraiment
comprendre du coup les objectifs des
deux institutions
et en effet on a trouvé que c'est
intéressant de dynamiser à travers un
concours de films sur smartphone l'image
de la cinémathèque puisqu'il existe
beaucoup d'action au forum des images
est peut-être trop peu à la cinémathèque
envers le public jeune c'est ça parce
que c'est vraiment un concours qui
s'adresse à une grand public et plus
quand même une cible un peu plus serré
qui est celle des 18 25 ans alors ce
projet vous l'avait nommé un coup de
films c'est un joli jeu de mots entre le
smartphone et le cinéma
il vous êtes un peu la directrice
artistique du projet c'est vous qui avez
eu l'idée du non non on l'a eu tous
ensemble on s'est réunis autour d'une
table et on s'est dit il faut qu'on
réponde de manière pertinente à nos deux
thématiques qui nous tenait à coeur
et donc on a trouvé ce jeu de mot assez
rigolo de coups de fil et associés aux
filles de coups de fil et on a voulu
aussi mettre l'accent avec la main qui
représente le téléphone voilà et en plus
cela maintient sur le logo
je vois qu'ils représentent
manière de téléphoner et puis le cadre
qui rappelle un peu l'intérieur d'une
caméra quand on filme donc le concours
démarre le 15 février et les candidats
ont jusqu'au 20 mai pour envoyer une
vidéo réalisée sur smartphone de deux
minutes maximum
arrêtez moi si je me trompe sur le thème
sur le chemin de la cinémathèque
française
c'était important pour vous on a choisi
ce thème pour mettre en avant a entendu
la cinémathèque française puisque c'est
quand même l'objectif premier de ce
concours là de faire connaître la
cinémathèque française de auprès des
jeunes puisque le concours s'intitule
bien la cinémathèque française by coûte
chine donc c'est la cinémathèque à
travers les yeux des participants de
goûter au concours coup de films donc
voilà la seule exigence de ce thème
c'est de laisser apparaître la
cinémathèque dans le film donc que ce
soit plus de 20 photos
peu importe il faut juste ça après les
participants peuvent laisser s'exprimer
leur originalité ça peut être un film
comique a filmé en noir et blanc un clip
un film d'animation
peu importe c'était pour ne pas réserver
le concours qu francilien mais vraiment
pouvoir l'étendre c'est ça sur toute
l'année il se défait alors marie vous
travaillez sur le règlement et les
partenariats
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres modalités
d'inscription un peu plus précise alors
en plus de celles que vous avez déjà
cités il faut être majeur après y'a pas
de limite d'âge donc ça reste quand même
un concours grand public aux étudiants
pas réservé qu'aux étudiants même si
c'est forcément au départ notre coeur de
cible il est ouvert vraiment aux
personnes au delà de 25 ans voilà donc
en plus le thème la vidéo de 2 minutes
et utiliser son smartphone donc toutes
les infos légal on peut les retrouver
sur le site dédié donc concours tirées
coup de films pourraient faire et on a
mis en place aussi une rubrique astuces
qui pourraient être très utiles pour les
participants dans lesquels ils pourront
trouver un petit peu les conseils pour
le montage et le tournage de leurs
filets ou alors on remarque que vos
affiches sont très différentes on va les
voir à l'écran la 1ère et la 2ème dégage
une atmosphère presque opposés on peut
dire il ya une raison précise as la mise
oui c'est justement pour montrer que
notre concours
on favorise l'originalité et qu'on ne se
ferme pas du tout à aucun thème on
impose uniquement la valorisation
d'acide
attaque française ou en tout cas
l'opinion des gens qui participeront et
donc on a fait un premier une première
affiche plus sur le trailer un peu
sombre et là une deuxième affiche plus
joyeuse sur le thème un petit peu de
l'amour d'accord il est vous êtes en
charge des relations presse et du
community management
alors vous avez une super communication
twitter facebook que vous organisez des
jeux concours
un site internet comment est ce que vous
avez choisi vos partenaires déjà peut
être présentée il ya eu gc la
cinémathèque on l'a dit et le pavé du
canal exactement et le fossoyeur de
films aussi je t'ai laissé marie
répondre à ce sujet là puisque est le
plus chargé des partenariats je suis
chargé justement des partenariats cure
notamment le fossoyeur de films donc le
fossoyeur de films alias françois thorel
qui est un youtube heures très reconnu
il a plus de 5000 follower sur youtube
est en fait il fait énormément de vidéos
sur le thème du cinéma dont des vidéos
qui sont pertinentes original et bien
monté donc on pourra vraiment utiliser
son oeil d'expert puisqu'il est
également membre du jury comme tous les
autres partenaires
donc j'essaie skywest notre école
l'institut supérieur de management de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
la librairie le pavé du canal et puis
aussi la cinémathèque française bien
entre nous pourquoi le pavé du canal
c'était important de en fait de rendre
les acteurs locaux dans le projet alors
tout à fait déjà c'est une bonne
première réponse et en plus le cinéma ça
se fait pas qu'à travers le film donc du
coup c'était important aussi d'avoir des
supports autre que la vidéo est donc à
travers le partenariat avec la librairie
on a l'occasion d'avoir de beaux livres
qui sont remis donc parmi les parmi les
loups
pour justement valorisé le cinéma à
travers une autre facette qui est le
papier et non la vidéo donc une bonne
communication vous espérer recevoir et
l'on reçoit d'ailleurs beaucoup de
vidéos va y avoir une présélection qui
va être rétablie une vingtaine à peu
près c'est ça exactement
donc nous tous les membres de l'équipe
en fait on va présélectionnés 20 vidéos
on va tous d'avoir vérifié que les
vidéos qu'on aura reçu respectent les
consignes qu'on aurait imposé comme la
durée de la vidéo comme le thème comme
le format de la vidéo on va aussi voir
si les vidéos sont de bonne qualité
parce que les 20 premières vidéos qu'on
nous on aura sélectionnés auront pour
vocation en fait à être projeté lors de
la cérémonie de remise des prix à la
cinémathèque française et on va aussi
voir l'originalité et la créativité
le montage est une fois que ces 20
vidéos seront présélectionnés le jury
alors composé de cinq personnes
regardent pas vu du canal à la marque
alban pardon il va m'en vouloir
gravel de l'ugc c'est exact et le
fossoyeur de films il y aura aussi un
représentant de l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
et puis et soraya taous donc de la
cinémathèque française donc
sélectionnera les trois premiers prix du
concours et il ya des lots vraiment
vraiment intéressant parce qu'un premier
prix il ya même une caméra à gagner
alors il ya des pass illimité d'un an
pour la cinémathèque des places
gratuites et puis un beau livre de
cinéma donc vraiment un concours
intéressant on va vous suivre tout au
long jusqu'au 20 mai donc vous avez
merci à vous quatre d'être venu en
plateau vous reviendrez donc nous en
dire plus sur l'avancement de ce beau
projet et en attendant je vous invite à
retrouver toutes les informations sur
concours tiré du cisq ou de films tout
attaché point fr et avant de se quitter
juste une date à noter dans votre agenda
vendredi 5 février 20h30 direction la
clé à saint germain en laye pour
retrouver le groupe de chanson française
debout sur le zinc et c'est la fin du
pioch que pour cette semaine je vous
retrouve avec plaisir la semaine
prochaine pour une émission musicale et
on se quitte d'ailleurs sur une extrait
de debout sur le zinc hier bonne soirée
à tous
est ce que je savais c'est tout voiture
et va doha dans sa mythologie grenade à
six clubs
ces shows that écrit
modifiant la sirène
leur promesse de bonheur
et tout ça sans peine assuré de
tataouine